joining us on the line is candice owens
she is a writer producer and
conservative commentator best-selling
author and of course the host of the
brand new show here on daily wear
premieres this
friday candace kenneth owens thanks so
much for joining the show great to talk
to you
excited to be back on so i'm going to
talk to you about the brand new show on
friday what we can expect
a little bit later but first i have to
ask you about the i would say
cultural milestone that was the grammys
last night it was just an incredible
display of shakespearean brilliance
i i'm just i'm glad to be living in a
time when if i ran the zoo
is too much for kids but simulated
lesbian sex acts on stage
is not only perfectly appropriate for
children but apparently the height of
our culture
i know and thank goodness our children
can no longer read the deplorable dr
seuss
but we are totally allowed to see these
lesbian simulations
uh i'm happy to say that i did not watch
a single second
of the grammys but i did watch obviously
the news clips and i saw exactly what
you're talking about
and it's funny and it's also despicable
and disgusting
um and everything that is rotten about
american culture the things that we hold
up and the things that we cancel
i mean it is incredible how feminist it
was i mean all i could think of is how
empowering it must be for women all over
america to watch this happen on stage
because obviously men would not want to
watch that right it was just for women i
mean
no men would ever want to watch
something like that i personally felt so
empowered
uh when i watched it this morning i said
wow finally i'm free
because that's what i actually want to
do uh uh you know what i want to do is
go out there and be half naked and to
simulate lesbian sex and i felt
um you know so held down by the
patriarchy prior to last night but now
i'm gonna go ahead and do that later on
today
yeah it's definitely it's definitely
freedom it does feel as though our our
culture is not just in a state of
collapse it is in a state of active
destruction of everything
that that is valuable i've been saying
that we don't have a culture and a
counter culture the way we used to
where there was sort of this dominant
traditional culture and there was a
counterculture the challenge some of
those things but created its own culture
now we just have an anti-culture and
that anti-culture is just dreck
designed to tear down things and that
seems like what
the grammys basically become it's just a
bunch of garbage designed to tear down
traditional structures and institutions
at any cost
and then you're rewarded for for doing
that apparently
yeah to me personally i think for a lot
of americans it sort of feels like we're
actually under attack like this does it
just it doesn't seem real you know what
i mean and i know that
i don't believe that the average
american thinks that that is good
right and yet we see that it's being
promulgated in the culture we see that
it's being perpetuated we see
that people are being held up as idols
when they do these sorts of things so it
makes you wonder who's promoting it
right
who is behind this push to tear down
american culture to tear down american
values
and to fundamentally weaken america at
the same time right because that's what
you're doing right
you're destroying values in the process
it always seems to me to be an attack on
the family what it means to be a family
um you know promoting whether it's the
trans agenda whether it's you know
lesbian of the lesbian agenda whatever
it is it always seems to be this attack
on
tradition cultural values making men
strong making
making women strong and keeping families
together
so i also wanted to ask you about the
most victimized person
in american and british society these
days that of course would be megan
markel
who is the most victimized princess in
the history i mean thoughts and prayers
to meghan markle
the most victimized person in the
history of humanity
uh i mean i i i have to say by law
apparently that i believe her when she
makes any accusation of any sort because
if i don't say that i believe
then i then i lose my job like sharon
osborne is about to lose her job or like
pierce morgan lost his job
according to uh the dictates of the
constitution of the united states and
apparently uh
all of the founding documents in in
britain according to magna carta
uh we have to agree with meghan markle's
self-perception of victimhood
and also her protestations that she
didn't marry into the royal family
for any career purpose she actually gave
up her career it turns out to become a
princess and then
have a line of business at netflix and
then also run for president
i mean it's an amazing i would say not
even a horizontal career move she had to
take a downgrade
from her job as a second-rate actress on
suits to do all of this so really
right he's a little dishonest
i feel like everyone's now promoting her
to the b list we had no idea who she was
prior to harry not a single american she
was off in canada somewhere doing some
show that nobody's heard of
uh but i'm glad that we've upgraded her
to second rate actress
and you are right i'm glad that you're
not questioning her narrative as you
know
um even the bible tells us women never
lie right in that chapter of genesis
women have never done anything wrong um
and so she's obviously telling the truth
about everything that's happened for her
uh look she's an opportunist and the
thing about her is she was a d-list
actress and now she is again being a
d-less actress no one's buying it
actually there was a poll that showed
that her likability went down uh which
was pretty hard because it was it was
floating at somewhere like 23
and now people like her even less
because she's just not good at selling
victims but she's not a good victim you
know there's people that you go
okay they're lying but i i'm inclined to
believe them there's nothing about her
story that makes any sense especially
when you say you had no idea who prince
harry was right you had no idea who the
royal family was
you thought you were gonna walk in and
shake the queen's hand i didn't know
that i had to curtsy or do anything
polite i thought
who is this woman isn't she just your
grandma um so she's so ridiculous
but you know the the more the serious
thing about this is that she's so
emblematic of leftist culture
of what hollywood is and what america is
going through the brits are very
surprised by this
suddenly cascading all of the uk as
racist and fundamentally backwards
because they don't have the same history
as america
and for me it really hits home because
my husband obviously is british he grew
up in london his father is a lord
his mother is a lady so it's so
frustrating for me to see her try
to export america's obsession with race
to the british people who just don't
care
about this sort of stuff they just don't
like you and it's just weird thing all
of a sudden
then minorities have this car in life
where if
we go through anything bad if somebody
doesn't like us it can never be just
because
life sucks or because people don't like
us it's always because i'm black
i'm a woman so if you don't like me it's
your fault and you have a problem and
you need to change it
we'll get to more with candace in just
one second and if you're betting on the
future of western culture well that's a
bad bet but here's
the thing you can have a lot of fun
betting on sports march is here
and march madness has officially begun
it is time for you to shoot your shot
score big
with non-stop action with my bookie
select the winners from 63 tournament
games in the my bookie bracket contest
for a chance at 10 grand in cash prizes
is only a dollar to enter it doesn't
matter whether you're filling out
multiple brackets betting the national
championship winner or simply looking
for player and game props
my bookie has you covered sign up today
at mybookie.ag use promo code shapiro to
secure a deposit bonus up to one
thousand dollars that's promo code
shapiro to claim your first
deposit bonus college ball nba nhl no
matter the sport no matter the minute
my bookie puts the action in your hands
with in-game live betting and with
choice from thousands of lines and odds
you can turn
any game day into payday bet anything
anytime
anywhere with my bookie i used my bookie
during the election
we bet on prop bets on on the various
debates what people are going to wear
it's a lot of fun
go check them out right now at anything
anytime anywhere with
my bookie it was funny because members
of the media were sort of
weirded out by the fact that so many
conservatives were coming to the defense
of the royal family because typically
conservatives are not a big fan of
monarchy but it does feel like once
again
every traditional institution in our
culture is being hollowed out you don't
have to be a fan of monarchy to
understand exactly what's going on here
this turned into a referendum on whether
the entire british history was replete
with racism and this was just the latest
reflection
of british racism and you as you
mentioned before it does feel like
we are under assault as conservatives or
it's just people who don't who want to
be left alone to live our lives with our
families
it feels like we're under a consistent
level of assault whether it is you know
stupid stories like this one which
actually have real ramifications they're
actual
there there were actual victims in the
story but none of them were meghan
markle the victims in this story are
people like sharon osbourne who's about
to lose her job
or piers morgan who lost his job at good
morning britain for committing the great
crime of saying he didn't believe
her because she's a horrible actress but
it's it's
penetrated to the point where even the
u.s military which i think most
conservatives thought of as the bastion
and repository of
a certain level of traditionalism i mean
this was a place where
masculinity has to be in high supply
because if it is not we've got a problem
on our hands
and now it seems like the military
itself the military infrastructure at
the higher levels
has been penetrated by woke ideology i
was saying on my show this morning that
you know when if you asked rank and file
members of the american military
whether they wildly disagreed with
tucker carlson's suggestion that perhaps
pregnant women
getting new uniforms was not at the top
of the list of military priorities
i think rank and file military members
would be like yeah clearly
tucker's right but if you ask the
higher-ups who are beholden to the biden
administration suddenly they have to
release videos and they are releasing
videos attacking private citizens
right exactly and and you're right
you're right to say if it seems like
it's coming from higher up we know
you know the average military man or
woman does not agree with this narrative
the average military
and a woman is not woke um so there's
something going on that feels a lot more
sinister
um and i'm sure you saw over the weekend
maybe it was the end of last week that
bill maher
you know maybe a little too late but is
now saying oh look this is problematic
america is turning into a culture of
wimps and china's getting stronger
right now in china you know the their
military uh their initiative right now
is to make sure that men are more manly
ironically you know we got into so much
trouble for possibly saying that men
should be manly
and now uh china is starting an actual
initiative to ensure that their men
are i should say toxically masculine or
just masculine
um and yet we're doing the exact
opposite so there there there are bigger
implications here
uh we do have foreign enemies china is a
problem right now
uh personally i think that they've got a
lot of control over the person sitting
in the oval office as well we know he
has a steep history with beijing
um and and nobody seems to be talking
about that aside from conservatives you
know realizing
that there are deeper implications here
um and all of it
all of this feels to me like an attack
on western civilization
altogether so that's sort of i think
what um
the synergy is between what's going on
in the uk the meghan markle this is the
reason conservatives care about it it's
not because we're like oh well we need a
king and a queen again
although the way that things are going
in america maybe we do
she's joking for those of you for those
of media matters we don't need a monarch
and candace is not saying that she's
joking just for the media matters people
out there
so so let's so one of the things that
that's become perfectly obvious in
virtually every aspect of the society is
the death of the meritocracy and the
left is really pushing hard for this is
the meritocracy has to go away
instead we're going to have woke
hierarchies or perhaps we're going to
simply adjudicate our problems with
reference to feelings but the
meritocracy is going away china
obviously
is not getting rid of the meritocracy
china is is actually ramping up its
meritocracy you have to pass all of
these tests to be able to
move into the middle class or get into a
university they have pretty stringent
tests with regard to how their military
operates
the united states is going precisely the
reverse we're getting rid of the
meritocracy with regard to how to get
into college we're getting rid of the
meritocracy for testing in the military
apparently we're talking about getting
rid
of the the gender neutral physical
fitness standards because
that might apparently cut against women
because it turns out men tend to
outperform women on physical fitness who
knew
um but you know all of this as you say
does feel like a real attack
so i wanted to ask you before we run out
of time here candace you have a new show
coming out
on friday with us here at the daily wire
i'm not
in nashville so frankly i have no idea
what exactly the show is going to be so
what is the show going to look like what
can what can subscribers expect we're
pretty excited about it
i think first and foremost you can you
can expect unregulated opinions uh we we
want people to disagree with us we want
to have conversations
we're never going to be offering up uh
those tired copy and pasted apologies
once you say something
that's true the next day the host comes
back and says i'm so sorry i realized my
ways are wrong sharon osbourne you are
more than welcome to join candace
um but we're creating a show that's
going to feel a lot more cultural you
know we're going to have obviously a
monologue
that's written by me every week that
will shape the show we'll have panelists
discussing uh the stories of the week
and again just hitting
um at what feels like a a massive hole
um where conservative voices are just
not being heard we're not allowed to be
culturally allowed to be celebrated
we're not allowed to be liked
um and our popularity is is not allowed
to be accepted by the mainstream so
um we're definitely going to have
interviews written in the dna of every
single episode and we are
definitely going to hit back at wolf
culture and talk a lot about what these
cancelings
really mean and who's really behind them
uh because i'm starting to realize that
i really don't think it's a left or
right issue it just feels like there's a
small group of people
uh that would like to see america suffer
well candace owens
check out her brand new show candace it
comes out this friday at dailywear but
only for members you have to go over to
dailywire.com
subscribe and use promo code candace to
get 25 percent off when you join it
daily where it's going
to be awesome you're going to want to be
a part of it candace thanks so much for
joining the show and we'll see you in a
bit
thanks for having me i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the ben shapiro show if
you did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content